so we were talking about
the wealth inequality that characterized
the gilded age but you were telling me
that that's not the only thing kim that
characterizes this period right what
really makes the gilded age happen
is what we call the second industrial
revolution
are you familiar with the first
industrial revolution but of course so
that was the revolution where they had
steam ships and canals and kind of this
early creation of the marcus system in
the united states say like 1820s 1830s
the second industrial revolution is is
more of a revolution of
mass production i would say
and ways of making
and shipping
and communicating
about business transactions and
materials that didn't exist before so
what are some of these disruptive
technologies
that are really poised to change the
shipment paradigm so okay so off the top
of my head
um
trains probably a huge deal right in
this period so we've got we've got all
this coal going and we've got and that
means that there's a lot of smelting
happening and that means that there's
also a lot of steel happening too
i think if i had to choose
one
most important technology of the gilded
age it would have to be steel
now it's not like steel didn't actually
exist right before this steel has been
around for
like millennia yeah i think so
millennium um but what happens in this
time period is there's a new process for
making steel it's called the bessemer
process
and the bessemer process basically makes
steel faster and it makes it cheaper
okay
and in this time period you know andrew
carnegie we talked about being this
major steel baron
railroads throughout the united states
partly supported majorly supported by
the u.s government and during this
period they lay 40 000 miles
of new tracks of rail that is so many
miles that is so many miles how long is
the united states from like los angeles
to new york like 3 000 miles 3 100 miles
uh yes so just imagine a nation where
most railroad tracks had gone through
sort of eastern coastal cities up until
1865 now the entire country is connected
by rail there is more rail in the united
states
in 1900 than all of europe combined so
so steel is this really so the bessemer
process of making steel is this
foundational technology that enables a
lot of the gilded age to happen right so
it enables the united states to move out
and also to connect markets right so you
can now take raw materials from the west
which is really important right that's
where the gold lives and also cattle
ranching right you take those things
from the west you take them to the
cities
to be processed then you take the fitted
the finished goods and send them back
out into the smaller towns so rail
facilitates all of that so this is this
is how my hometown became notorious yeah
of chicago so there would be cattle
drives i guess then that came exactly
from the west and then they would all be
slaughtered and processed in chicago
right yeah um i'm a native pennsylvanian
you're a native chicagoan and we are
born from steel places as the steel
industry really grew up in pittsburgh um
and what i think is really interesting
about steel too is that it's like a
self-sustaining industry right because
you need the steel to make the railroads
right
and then
the railroad industry
pays for the creation of steel
which facilitates
the creation of more railroads which
necessitates the creation of more steel
and it's just like this never ending
boom in steel in the gilded age so
steel facilitates the united states
moving outward but it also facilitates
the united states moving upward oh i see
that was good yeah you like that yeah so
steel allows for the construction
of buildings that are taller than ever
before so what is this building here
this building here is the home insurance
building in chicago i don't believe it
is there anymore
um and do you know what is special about
the home insurance building no what's
what's special about it the home
insurance building is considered to be
the world's first skyscraper
yeah it looks pretty pretty short for a
skyscraper by modern standards i mean i
couldn't build a building that tall it's
10 stories tall
and what you can do with steel is build
these steel frame structures
that allow you
without using stone there's kind of like
a steel
cage underneath the facade of this
and so
you can build buildings that are taller
oh man while having windows it's like a
faraday cage but there was terrible cell
phone reception in there i imagine so
yeah there were no cell phones at this
time all right so you know what else
made these tall buildings possible
except for the steel structures uh was
it elevators it was totally elevators
yes see you're better at this than you
thought yeah ah this is the the time of
the invention of the otis elevator and
this is my little an elevator entrance
that nice you could go to the top of a
tall building without having to walk up
37 flights of stairs which is pretty
sweet for our efficiency if not maybe
our waistlines okay so what we've got
we've got this steel process which
enables the construction of tons and
tons of rail and tons and tons of
buildings of new buildings where you can
put more industry and more people
and that enables cities to grow
and wealth to grow yeah exactly so there
are more and more people flooding into
cities by
1870 there are more people working for
other people for wages living in cities
than people who work for themselves
which is a new era in the american
economic system there's some other
really important business technologies
that grow up in this time period as well
so there's uh the telephone
um which
makes it possible to do business
transactions on the spot right um
revolutionized the speed of business
very much the same way that the internet
is going to revolutionize the speed of
business in the 1990s you also have
refrigeration
which you would not think would be that
big of a deal
um but think about how it allows you to
move
food stuff sure all over the country to
new markets you were just talking about
chicago right so the only way that
cattle could be driven into chicago
slaughtered and then have meat sent to
all the other markets in the united
states was through refrigerated train
cars and they have similar things for
steam ships that allow people to for
example bring oranges from florida to
new york so is this web of markets that
are connecting the united states and
this is my terrible drawing of the
united states but you know rail
and
then ships
make it possible for all of these
markets
to connect together over time and over
space that's super cool you know the
railroad was even so important in this
time period that in a way it invented
the modern system of time
right because before the railroad
localities would just decide when noon
was based on when the sun was highest in
the sky sure which meant that it didn't
matter whether or not it was the same
time in kansas city as as in st louis
but once you have a train connecting
them you know the st louis train gets in
at 1205. if you're off you know you'll
miss your train or that might lead to a
collision of trains if they don't know
when the other train is going to be
coming through yeah okay so inventions
of the gilded age intra-national train
travel yes the telephone refrigeration
for meat the bessemer process for steel
and the standardization of time all of
those things and i would say the last
thing that might be really important
here is also electrification
yeah and like steel
you know
electricity was not invented in the
gilded age but what happened was the
spread of the light bulb
in both homes and businesses which meant
that you could work longer hours
you didn't sleep as long actually the
amount of sleep that people got per
night switched from about nine hours
before electrification to about seven
hours after so thomas edison is
literally responsible for robbing us of
sleep but it also made it possible for
workers to work longer hours and it
significantly reduced the risk of fire
in businesses which meant you could
invest in them with more confidence oh
because they didn't have gas lamps that
could burst into flame right awesome
well that's super cool
so hooray gilded age right right um and
i think one thing that's important to
understand
about these technologies
is that one of the
goals of these technologies was to make
it possible to produce things faster but
also to produce them with less skilled
workers right because a skilled worker
someone who knows a craft
and can produce a finished item from
start to finish that takes a long time
and it costs a lot of money right this
is the difference between buying a suit
off the rack and having a bespoke suit
if you want to pay someone for that time
and talent you're going to pay a lot
but if you can make something on a
machine
then you can make a lot of them very
quickly and you don't need someone who
is you know an expert tailor you just
need someone who can operate a sewing
machine to do a couple of seams
so what they're trying to do here with
this innovation is spread consumer goods
spread a higher standard of living but
they're also doing that at the price of
having less skilled workers making much
smaller wages